une vague verte déferle sur la france
les écologistes se sont emparés de
plusieurs grandes villes ce dimanche une
journée marquée par une abstention
historiquement haute
ce sont environ 6 électeurs sur dix
appelé aux urnes qui ne se sont pas
rendus dans leurs bureaux de vote
qu'importe pour europe ecologie les
verts qui s'impose au sortir de ces
élections comme le nouveau poids lourd
de la gauche sur l'échiquier politique
français à lyon
le triomphe est total la métropole
revient à bruno bernard et la ville à
grégory douce et au nez et à la barbe du
camp de gérard collomb ancien ministre
de l'intérieur d' emmanuel macron et
maire de la capitale des gaules durant
près de deux décennies
lyon apaisé cela signifie qu'on a le
devoir de protéger la santé celle des
humains mais aussi celle de tous les
êtres sensibles de tout ce qui vit de
tout ce qui pousse de tous ceux qui
bruissent car nous avons besoin les uns
des autres
lyon troisième ville de france a le
devoir de tracer le chemin celui de la
transition écologique et de l'humanisme
la bascule s'opère également à
strasbourg et bordeaux qui passe sous
pavillon écolo dans la capitale
girondine
pierre hurmic arrache la victoire d'une
courte tête si à marseille le succès de
l'écologiste michèle ruby rola à la tête
d'une coalition de gauche est encore
incertain anne hidalgo guerre de son
siège à l'hôtel de ville de paris
après avoir mené une campagne résolument
verte vous avez choisi l'espoir vous
avez choisi le rassemblement vous avez
choisi un pari qui respire un pari plus
agréable à vivre une ville plus
solidaire qui ne laisse personne sur le
bord du chemin
le revers est lourd en revanche pour la
république en marche
le parti majoritaire à l'assemblée
nationale ne glane aucune grande ville à
l'exception du havre dont les habitants
ont réélu le premier ministre edouard
philippe
un tournant vert à prendre en compte
pour le président emmanuel macron qui
devrait prochainement fixé le cap de la
fin de son mandat